the State Department is now asking
Americans not to take cruises while the
corona virus outbreak is still a threat
a cruise ship with at least 21 cases on
board will dock in Oakland today after
waiting off the California coast for
days a man who traveled on the ship last
month had the virus and died from it
last week Carter Evans is in San
Francisco across the bay from Oakland
Carter what's next for those passengers
well first that ship is going to pass
right under the bay bridge behind me on
its way to the Port of Oakland the first
people to be evacuated will be those who
require medical attention they're going
to be taken to area hospitals the rest
are going to be transferred to military
bases around the country here in
California but also in Texas and Georgia
where they'll be tested for the virus
and he'll for another two weeks the
spread of carota virus on the Grand
Princess set off a massive operation to
keep the 3,500 passengers in quarantine
after this ship docks in Oakland
individuals will not come into contact
with general public at any point state
and city leaders surveyed the dock
Sunday they say US passengers will be
bused to one of four military bases the
foreign passengers from 54 different
countries will return on charter flights
we have strict protocols as relates to
these charter flights that are
completely separate from the general
population and the terminals at hand the
process could take two to three days but
it's a relief for thousands of
passengers who've been stuck in their
rooms like Jun and Wayne Holland from
Texas I'm a little concerned because I
recently had lung cancer and I had
better portion of my age I think I'm in
excellent health California is also
monitoring more than 1500 people who had
previously traveled on the Grand
Princess around the country Iowa
announced its first infection Sunday and
officials in Washington DC released new
details on one of the first cases
they're the head of a prominent
Georgetown church who was hospitalized
out of an abundance of caution Christ
Church has cancelled all of its services
and shut its doors until further notice
in New York State the number of cases
surged past 100 Columbia Hofstra and
Barnard are canceling some classes this
week after students had possible
exposure to the virus north of New York
City around 4,800 public school students
in Scarsdale will be out of school for
more than a week after a teacher tested
positive the governor declared a state
of emergency the more tests we run the
more positive people we will find the
better we can do the containment and the
wife of a New York City lawyer
hospitalized for the virus released a
statement over the weekend Adina darboux
says her husband Lawrence is in critical
condition but he is a tenacious person
in all aspects of his life and I know
he'll come out of this straw
now after passengers disembarked from
the Grand Princess today the crew will
be quarantined on the ship Michelle all
right Thank You Carter